hey we're back here on the gamespot
stage they to of III proper and I am
joined by ian from ccp hey hey d-man am
going to see you again so in works and
you you basically the mind the brain the
body behind eval curries are correct one
of the many good brains behind it well
no but it was your idea right well it
was not my idea I was one of the first
guys in our Iceland studio to get
involved yeah basically you know once I
saw my first glimpse of like a space sim
on the oculus rift I want it in and so
yeah we're very excited to get on it and
it's been over a year already yeah it's
crazy because it still feels like this
this new thing but yeah it's been around
for a year that's as crazy must been
kind of weird watching your your baby
like grow and morph into this it's kind
of big thing that I guess yeah you know
III was we're really kicked off for
Valkyrie we originally showed it at fun
fest 2013 and I'm people got very
excited about it there but i think that
was like that was the eve audience right
yeah we like is this is ever gonna be
excited lately you know we showed it
first to our eve audience and they said
you know great but when we showed it to
like everybody else at e3 that you know
then it just exploded we started winning
you know awards at the show it was at a
really exciting time and here it is now
you know running on you've got on that
development kit see for oculus right and
also project Morpheus and em it's bill
in Unreal Engine 4 so I think we've got
some writing about some brand new
gameplay to show the guys at home just
now as well obviously you know we can
all put oculus rifts on you right now
but this is it is very different in VR
and so if anybody who gets an
opportunity to try it we totally
recommend that they do yeah okay so talk
us through this add this new gameplay
footage that what's rare Cubs here comes
right and so when you look down because
of the head tracking when you can look
all around the interior of the cockpit
here you're seeing something locking on
missiles and they're using the head
tracking to actually guy
it's a really powerful feeling people
love this so this is all this as I was
saying install the air Unreal Engine 4
so what exists give was this enable GU
as developers to to add to Valkyrie
Unreal Engine 4 has a really powerful
good oculus integration it also has sony
Morpheus integration and so we're able
we've really improved the graphical
fidelity of the game it's it runs
comfortably at about 60 frames per
second which you know compared to most
other games is way higher we've what
we've got here in this very latest build
is an innovation from oculus themselves
from John Carmack called time warp yeah
you mentioned this time warp thing right
so it's like predicting future frames or
somethings that all right do not even
try again need to explain how this works
okay imagine I'm misery it works through
magic and wizardry my ticket was a dream
of John Carmack and I saw it for the
first time actually on Tuesday oh really
on our build it's not new and it's
difficult for us to tell but it feels
like it's running over 90 frames it's
just incredible you when you have the
rift on and you shake your head you know
this is your very quickly looking around
the game and we're not missing a frame
there's no shearing there's no motion
blur is a really amazing inhibition and
you know they're not done yet it just
keeps getting better so it's really
exciting to work on this is I mean it
must be quite difficult working as well
they were all the thing on a game for
hardware that is not finished yet you
know that is still in development he
never does give a change especially on
your toes come I mean what if they add
like I don't know smell-o-vision yeah
and then you got to get a suddenly
incorporate that please don't do that
but like I mean if you actually that's a
good question if you could add anything
in to oculus to project Morpheus other
functionality what would it be what
would you like to be able to include at
your mouth through experience oh we're
working on things like rig skeleton so
that when people move their fingers on
the gamepad the fingers in the game
would move we're not quite there yet but
it's definitely something we're going to
work on we also have with the Morpheus
you have the moon
controller so the the actual dualshock 4
has a sensor in it and therefore moving
the pod will so your avatar as either
the path we could move it as well and so
it's whenever you add that kind of stuff
people start the house you know you get
those tingles when you realize that this
virtual world that surrounds you that
immerses you you get real feedback in
your actions and outside of the game
2nite that's what I did then I am at a
fan fest this year you guys here we're
showing some like old footage this is uh
this is from last year so you can see my
sorrow may come yeah yeah so it really
is quite different hosting unity engine
and everything this quick purple I mean
we all this gorgeous but it well we
created this in a month ya know this
version ah so what we worked on the
Unreal for version four by five or six
months now so yeah all right base 20
guys whereas this version you see was
done with about less than 10 Wow okay in
our spare time as well haha I must be
really fun be able to like devote
yourself to that nurse is that is this
the one project you work on there yes
it's all early Italian weltering awesome
now at first you guys had a few a nose
piece you know you mentioned that katee
sackhoff is the voice you know Starbuck
she is what is around round is the
leader of the Valkyrie you know we're
developing this lower for the Valkyrie
universe Valkyrie you know resides sort
of inside the the lure of the universe
but isn't connected to tranquility the
eve-online cluster it's Katie here III
is she come along too he's not but she's
stated that she definitely wants to make
it the Fun Fest in Reykjavik next year
that would be a real treat for our fun
of you bear yeah if you got not matter
but uh we've flown over to LA to record
to do some of the voice-over our current
version of the game has Katie speaking
to you you've tried a very beginning of
that game plate is very deliberate she's
like listen to my voice and it's like
hinting like you must recognize my voice
you must be much battles and Kitty
speaks you listen yeah exactly that's
great man well M so what else what else
you guys you've always got this new time
warp tech what else is new in the bill
that you're showing off is it the same
mission builders
very closely related to the build that
we showed at fan fest which was you know
only weeks ago for us here at e3 you
know most of these people don't didn't
get the opportunity to come out to
Iceland so we're just showing them where
we where we got to for that big public
showing back in new castle where we
develop Valkyrie we're working on just
the whole rest of the game many more
ships a lot more great art all those
little innovations with the VR that I
mentioned about the rig scale and it's
going to be we're gonna show a lot more
in the next few months who I mean the
demos excuse me the demos that um you've
shown off when I played there are always
those that they're really short and
characters like three minutes yeah it's
a plan to kind of to have all their all
the game modes ladies short brief
dogfights you relatively short we see
EVE Online is the game that you play for
like huge long sessions maybe like four
to six hours whereas dust 514 is maybe
more liked up to two hours and valkyrie
would be the game you play for like
20-30 minutes it's so intense it's so
immersive that even in the three minutes
that we do in these demos that we bring
to the shows it's such an intense
experience people get a real kick out of
it but yeah when you're playing Valkyrie
at home you'll be playing it for longer
may be anywhere between 20 and 30
minutes would be my my guess right now
yeah may I do you have any plans to do
you like these are obviously situational
kind of life multiplayer maps so this is
kind of what battle maps what they're
like do you have any plans to do
missions where you might be traversing
areas of space or they're all just gonna
because I know you've always said it's
like a dog fighting simulator yeah so
far we've mostly been working with like
real kind of like ballerinas where we
very much like design them to have
points of interest that are like you
know great to fly through there's some
really interesting like MOPP level so
we're working on back in back in
Newcastle and thankfully with the EVE
universe that we have a vast amount of
content to draw from we can really skip
ahead on that because we have 11 years
of art creation behind us are you any
plans you like recreate like battles
that have happened in the eve university
might stick people in them up so
we do our crest I lead designer talk
that farm fest about you know I'm op
called called necropolis it's really
like the graveyard of an EVE Online
bottle this year in 2014 and eve online
we had the biggest bottle ever Bala
where I think it was three hundred
thousand dollars worth equivalent rivlin
$300,000 of ships were destroyed in one
bottle and so you know we can just take
screenshots of that happening live in
EVE Online and within you know weeks
have an eval curry equivalent that a
players can fly through here must be
quite nice because you know Eva's is
seen as one if you don't play it can be
seen is this kind of quite intimidating
quite mind boggling thing but there
might be nice to have like Valkyries its
most people's favorite game that they
don't play exactly how completely you
know I find it fascinating but I've only
played a few hours of a mostly uh-huh
but like Valkyrie is the opposite
Valkyrie is like super easy it's a
really accessible way for people to
enjoy the eve universe to you know to we
have these such beautiful ships we have
11 years of Lord draw from and for us
we're just really excited yet to bring
people an alternative experience that
allows them to be involved and enjoy our
products yeah well I'm just gonna do at
this point if you don't mind is that if
you guys are watching at home if you
have any questions for Ian about eve
valkyrie just the best way to do that is
to send me a tweet in fact i can for as
robber got her open right here that's at
cam4 as Rob there might be on my lower
third coming three we wish wish your
lower 3rd here comes there it is magic I
was amazed controlled that power of my
mind and Ian I still have a fewer
questions for you though that's okay so
am what's it like working with morpheus
that's what I want to know it's really
great like Sony are really big into VR
yeah like cuz it wasn't a huge part of
the prescott but it was kind of like you
know they they were like oh we love the
camera under they had that brilliant
little giant Microsoft or like we love
our camera which you never forced you to
buy and that was pretty good but then it
was then like used as a way to almost I
felt it was more of a tease for what's
to come on the future you're telling me
they're quite committed now are they
you know normally what I see with these
shows is there's usually one message and
I think between Sony and Microsoft they
were you know trading over games
Morpheus will have its day we've
actually been working with morpheus for
a year now wow you can't i'm keeping
that secret i was to be campus we score
we first saw it you know a while ago you
know and we love working with sony and
the headsets come a long way i always
think about the ergonomics of these
headsets and it's got some really good
ergonomics it's a it looks really you
know good it feels good and it's you
know it's 1080p is to go great
characteristics and we're really excited
that ps4 owners will be able to play
Valkyrie so III in like five years time
do you think I think it's we're going to
see a much bigger fvr presence basically
I mean wife it could go really far it
could be that you know vr takes over I
mean when you try VR it is such a
intense experience I really believe that
there's a huge appetite for more VR
experiences the gaming you just get such
a you know such a great journey from a
great VR experience it's just going to
be exciting the that more people will
get the opportunity to play it I don't
know a lot of people who try BR who
aren't converts I guess that's maybe one
of the challenges to write because I
mean I was always interested in it but
it wasn't until I you know we got a kit
in the office in the UK and I put it on
there walked around that Tuscan villa
and then fell a bit ill was until I did
that that I felt wait a minute this this
could be pretty cool and then then then
actually sitting down and the games like
Valkyrie has been what's got me quite
excited about it you know I'm certainly
I'm not completely convinced I'll be
honest about which games that don't
involve you sitting down or or moving
very slowly anything with fast-paced I'm
still worried that it's going to be you
know nausea and his motion sickness are
always going to be a thing because
anything which is different which your
brain ceases being different from what
it expects can be an issue mean how do
you feel about you think we're gonna get
think anyone will ever crack like be
able to play like say Skyrim or a game
of that caliber and that kind of setting
NVR thing as possible I
yeah I think VR has challenges but the
brains that are behind the efforts to
overcome these challenges like let's not
write them off you know I I really
believe that the progress that we've
seen in just one year is just
mind-blowing I suppose really isn't as
embassy isn't it yes exactly and
therefore we're we're getting there and
the desire is behind it you know we saw
with Facebook's acquisition of oculus
like this is good news for all of ER
because it just shows that you know
people really believe you know that this
is not only as a common but like it's
coming soon and when it comes it should
be a really high quality experience
speaking of speaking of when things rest
you can align when it what do we have
any idea when is Valkyrie gonna be
finished I know and it was gonna be
playable he wants people can actually
buy you know like a Morpheus or or an
oculus but when are you guys Valkyries
released it will be closely related to
those of the Morpheus on the awesomest
have to wait and see really of course I
know of course you do but you're not
gonna tell me oh yeah that's right all
right get off this days that Ian it's
been a pleasure having you very much of
course